welcome back to CBS mornings where we
have got a story for you earlier this
month 35 year old Sheldon Thomas walked
out of a Brooklyn New York courtroom
free after almost two decades Behind
Bars Thomas was arrested back in 2004
for murder after an eyewitness pointed
to a picture of a guy named Sheldon
Thomas in a police lineup of photos but
the man in the image was actually a
different person entirely happened to
have the same name and as we stepped
through the circles of absurdity here
that guy also had no link to the case
nevertheless prosecutors continued to
focus on the Sheldon Thomas they had in
custody which eventually led to his
wrongful conviction Thomas talked to our
Lilia Luciano just days after his
release in his very first TV interview
I'm waiting for this my whole life
Sheldon Thomas was 16 when police took
down the door of his home and locked him
up now 19 years later he's been
effectively exonerated how have you been
sleeping I really haven't yeah
um I've I've just been rested not really
sleeping yeah still trying to grasp the
fact that
I'm not in the cage anymore that I'm
actually being treated with respect and
love and dignity the way you're seeing
the way people look at you the way
people talk to you or listen to you like
a human
because when you're behind them when
you're Behind the Walls you don't
you don't get that you get
the worst
of mankind they say the word through the
words treat you the worst
in in a crazy way sometimes you start to
feel as if they're right
after it's been done to you for so long
constantly constantly constantly
you start to feel like well maybe they
all right you lose out of your own
Humanity
and that's the
psychological
chest that goes on within Thomas was
convicted for second-degree murder in
the December 2004 death of a 14 year old
boy in Brooklyn attorneys William Casten
and Leslie ressinger have worked with
Thomas for more than a decade they say
the case should have never even made it
to trial how much of his case was based
on Lies 100 from the police interaction
to him every party fails him in the
system in a pre-trial hearing a
detective lied then admitted to lying on
the stand and the case still moved
forward he has arrested based on
a photo that is not his the people
involved in decision making refused to
accept the fact that a mistake was made
how can a jury reach a fair verdict
it was rigged from the start the unit
that reviewed his case after years of
failed appeals concluded that Thomas was
denied due process at every stage and
found one of the detectives involved had
been harassing Thomas after a prior
arrest and lied about knowing him did
you ever feel like they were targeting
you specifically most definitely it was
wrong it was illegal
and
they shouldn't have done it this is why
all this burden is placed on me to this
day it should have been the other way
around you're innocent until proven
guilty for my lenses where I see life is
always like that for people like me
for people that look like me it's always
like that
you're guilty until you actually prove
that you're innocent nearly two decades
later
who finally stepped into what still
feels like a mirage of freedom I haven't
even cried yet since I've been home like
I haven't even got to the point where it
actually hit me I still have dreams
about being in prison I'm scared to go
to sleep you're scared you're dreaming
yeah as the days go by
it Dawns on me
a little bit more a little bit more
physical
conviction is granted but a hearing this
month Thomas shared how his Hope was
sustained for so long by releasing
resentment when I was sentenced
tell Judith said that I deserve to spend
the rest of my life a person he was
wrong
I didn't deserve what happened and
I'm forgiven and yet he still trusts
that the pendulum can swing in the
direction of Justice it's not the system
it's the people because the people is
the system the people
is
the driving force of the will that makes
it turn it's the people so you have to
be more Mindful and be more selectful
of Who You assigned these roles I mean
it sounds to me like you still believe
in the system
if the right people were in place most
definitely
most definitely and the right people
that know how to exercise Mercy I know
I've lost 20 years already but
ultimately I prevail
I don't like losing so I have to let go
because I don't want that to be what
defines me as a human as a person
so yeah it goes into the universe what
would you like to Define you people
getting to know me
my qualities my personalities my
ambitions the person the human
I want love to Define me part of that
ambition is to help others in a similar
plight no I've left a lot of people that
I believe is innocent behind I think
about them every night
I think about them every day and every
night Sheldon says he can't sleep
because he's afraid that he's going to
wake up and it was all a dream he can't
sleep because of the other inmates he
met up at Attica who he believes are
there innocent we reached out to the
detective that we mentioned in this case
who was in the involved in the original
arrest that he said he did not want to
comment
um you know here's one thing that the
attorney told me when you when you
commit a crime and you serve your
sentence when you walk out there is
resources there is assistance for him
they just open the door and you're on
your own so he gets no assistance
whatsoever nothing right now he's
relying on his elderly mother to who's
working a second shift to support him
and on crowdfunding that his attorney
set up yeah and eventually perhaps he
may Sue and maybe he'll win but he's not
ready for that right now he's just
focusing what's it like for him to be
around people well that's what he was
saying he said we were walking around
Central Park and he said when you're in
prison the only time you get outside you
you're in the yard and if somebody gets
close to you it's not a good thing it's
not a good thing you're going to get
attacked so he he feels like that
self-preservation means isolation and
even with his family he says I feel so
bad because they reach out to me and I
just need the Solitude yes I I hope
really he will allow himself a good cry
he certainly deserves and needs that but
I Marvel that he can sit here today
after the Injustice that happened to him
and say I forgive them I would still
need help on that I mean and I want love
to Define it yeah he he's going to need
a lot of you know therapy and and we
talked so much I wish I wish I could
share everything but he did I asked them
what got you through it and he said
Victor Frankel's book emances and search
for me one of the greatest books I've
read it over and over and he read about
this man in a concentration camp and he
said well at least that's not this and
if he can get through it and all those
lessons got him looks incredible story
he's an amazing human being yeah
incredible Grace the most inspired
person I've met in my life wow I get
that saying because you've met a lot of
people yeah Lilia thank you very much